hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast and presentation you
multiplex encounter Plex set reagents an
alternative to qPCR technology presented
by christian model i'm susie valdez of
lab Bruce and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are excited to
bring you this educational virtual
conference presented by lab roots and
sponsored by nano strings technology
here's how this presentation will work
today we want to hear from you so
questions comments and even answers can
be submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen we'll try
to get to everyone but if not we'll make
sure to follow up with you by email you
can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you cannot hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button at the lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on a seat
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I'd now
like to introduce today's speaker
Christian Lydell welcome sir Thank You
Suzie I appreciate that very much
we here at Dartmouth got our naina
string system back in November 2012 so
we've had the system about five years
now and one thing we really liked about
the system was it kind of bridged that
gap between qpcr technology and micro
arrays it was more geared towards the
micro arrays as you'll see initially but
now with the new Plex set reagents
coming online they've filled that gap in
so they're really killing that
completely and covering that nice gap
between qpcr and micro arrays with some
great technology that I'd like to share
with you today first of all let's go
through the naina string basics of what
their standard essays are usually they
enable a customer to Express
do gene expression on 12 unique samples
and look at up to 800 targets or genes
within a single run and the real trick
to the Nano string are the probes that
they used in their system here let's go
through those real quick first there is
a capture probe and it consists of 50
bases that match 50 bases of your target
sequence and on the end of that capture
probe is a biotin molecule and then
there is the reporter probe it too has
50 bases that match a different 50 bases
of your target probe and on the end of
that is a barcode that consists of six
different fluorescent molecules and that
barcode is specific to each individual
target you are looking at and we'll go
through that a little bit more as we
come as we move on so once you have a
hydrogen event taking place between your
target and your probes which you see in
the bottom demonstrated in the bottom
there you have a nice hundred bases of
pretty much continued contiguous with a
capture probe on London and in a
reporter probe on the other end so the
process goes a lot like goes like this
you mix your messenger RNA up with your
capture probes and your reporter probes
and you do an overnight hybridization
and then you come in in the following
morning and you're going to take that
mixture and you're going to set it into
a prep station which is an automated
system and what that system is going to
do is it's going to remove the excess
capture probes and reporter probes away
from the hybridized the correctly
hybridized complexes that are in the
solution once those are removed it will
then deposit the hybridized probes into
a cartridge like the one you see in the
upper
right hand box but the lower left side
of that and there what will happen is
the hybrid I probes will bind to the
cartridge and that's where that avidin
molecule is coming in with the strechted
and the bison molecules is attaching to
the streptavidin coated bottom of that
cartridge from there what happens is an
electrical field is put across the
cartridge itself and those hybrid hybrid
complexes lay flat all in the same
direction exposing the barcodes and
laying all those complexes out in a
single direction so that they can then
be counted and digitally analyzed so
what is Plex said exactly this bridges
that gap like I was saying earlier it
enables the customer to do gene
expression on 96 instead of just 12 but
up to 96 samples in a single run it also
it all and you're just looking at 12 to
24 targets with the Plex set instead of
looking at up to 800 with the Plex set
you can go up to 48 genes if you're
doing 296 world plates at the same time
so that's a possibility to bring it up
to there but to run for the most part
you're looking at between doing 12 and
24 genes currently this essay is set to
use with a messenger RNA but the DNA and
other assays using Plex set are under
development right now and in the Plex
set we have 8 different tubes
represented at the bottom of the slide
there of and each of those eight tubes
has their own unique probe sets and
we'll go through that some more here
coming up
so let's take a look at the probe set
for the probes for the Plex set you can
see there's a difference here compared
to the others first you have your
reporter tag and on the end of that
reporter tag you have some specific
specific base bases that are unique to
that reporter tag you also have your
capture tag that has its own unique
sequences and in this case what you're
going to do is you're allowed to go out
and develop the probes yourself so you
can choose those probes and then on the
end of those probes we will you'll have
put the unique sequences that will
capture the reporter tag or the capture
tag onto the various probes that you
have so once there's those hybridize
together what you're having is a nice
complex informing the similar complex
that you have when you're using the
normal nano string but this allows you
to some more flexibility with the probes
you want to use so once that hybridize
and now with your target and the hybrid
AI hybridization happens all at the same
time you don't need to do separate
hybridizations or anything here it's all
mixed together and it's a single
hybridization event so once you have
that what you're looking at is your
reporter tag there with it's a unique
basis specific to probe a and its unique
basis hybridizing - it's it's 50 bases
of the target and then you have your
probe B with its unique sequences to the
capture tag and its unique sequences to
your nucleic acid target also so you get
the exact same complex that you do with
standard Nana string assays
and the workflow with both of regular
nano string and the Flex set is
virtually identical and you can use a
lot of the same sample types FFPE works
really really well in these assays and
you tend to use about a 100 nanograms
with that you can adjust that depending
on how degraded it may or may not be but
you can also use non fixed samples the
total RNA or in the real sweet spot of
this is using cell lysate sin stead of
having to do the extractions of the RNA
yourself and typically it depends on the
type of assay and the cells that you're
using but you can use anywhere from 25
to 100 nanograms of total RNA or
approximately 5000 cells and up from
that so you don't need a whole lot to do
these assays those essays are scalable
if you do an overnight multiplex
hybridization and with the Nano string
with the old nano spring you used to do
one tube per sample but now we're
putting multiple two samples into each
tube and then you're going to put that
into a fully automated system their
sprint system is shown here but it could
be a Mac system where you're using a
prep station and you're going to
essentially put the samples into these
automated systems and they will take it
from there once you have that finished
and you have your barcodes counted
you're going to take that information
and stick that into there and solver
software now this software is completely
free and comes with your kits in a USB
Drive it so what you'll do is you'll
take your kits you'll upload the
reference file that that that helps it
see what barcode is a match to what gene
or a target site
and then take it through the in solver
software to get your results and it
really is that simple so setting up the
Plex set now here are the eight Plex up
to that we are showing you a little
earlier here and you notice that the
eight tubes each consists of 24 unique
barcodes so it's unique for each of the
tubes a through H so in a total you have
192 of barcodes through a set of the
eight tubes here and you're going to set
those you'll have those and then you're
going to be using your samples and you
can use up to 96 samples and a 96-well
plate you don't have to use 96 but you
know if you want to maximize your
results and and and if you can 96 works
great here so here's the flow for the
Plex set workflow that is so what you're
going to do is you're going to be adding
your samples in each of the individual
wells and then each Plex set tube is
going to be added in the row that it
belongs all those tubes come labeled to
match the specific row that they need to
go in so whether it's so you rows a
through H and you'll fill those in
across
into the plate so you're adding 8
microliters of high buffer and the code
sets and your probe sets for a and B and
then you're going to add 7 microliters a
sample for a 15 micro liter
hybridization hybridization reaction
you're going to let that hybridize for
16 hours at 67 degrees then in the
morning you can come in and here's the
real trick is these samples then get
pulled into 12 different tube samples
that are provided in the kit and fit
either directly into the prep station
or they'll go into a cartridge if you
have the Sprint system and then you're
processing these things just like you
would any other Nana string product once
once those are cleaned up and you have
things counted and you in the digital
counter or the Sprint system it's done
in the same same instrument it will go
through and count and you can see the
barcodes all lined up there and I'll
reamp aside that each barcode each
unique barcode is specific is specific
to a unique target and it just goes
through council the barcodes and
tabulates that for it for you so then
you'll take those results and stick them
into the end ends oliver software you
load those up it does a QC check off for
you which happens quite quickly
it looks at your positive and negative
controls and any other parameters that
it may see like a density of the counts
and then it allows you to move through
the software and allows you to quickly
normalize and analyze your data and the
output is much like the table that you
see there you have samples and positive
and negative controls and endogenous
controls and of course your target sites
we're all in there and once you have
them in that table then you can move to
several options that the in solver
software has for you you can take that
and make box plots based on treatment
groups or scattered plots of all the
genes to to look at that you also have
the ability to do volcano plots and
other other analysis
and clustering and heat mapping which
most people tend to use with this data
and we'll show you some of some heat
maps and and examples of these but with
some of the research that we're going to
show you today
so let's talk about designing your
probes yourself we said that this is
something you do yourself so you're
going to choose what probes you want and
and in general most target sequences can
be designed for the Plex assays if you
have a 5 5 5 or plus based mutation in a
30 to 50 base pair range this usually
will allow the probes the Nano string
probes to just discriminate between the
different targets so that gives you a
lot of leeway obviously novel sequences
are very easy to design and once you
have these design what you're going to
do is then send that off to Nanna string
and let them check those designs for you
make sure that they don't see anything
wrong with them or if they have a better
suggestion within the same area they may
give that to you many of these many
probes and so forth especially when it
comes to endogenous controls they
already have a lot of sequences worked
out for those so it's very easy to have
them check that over to you check that
over for you then they'll give that back
to you and then you can take those to a
local ala go house or if you have
someone who makes all of those in-house
and have these made directly for you
typically what we do here is we order
from IDT and we're able to get these
things they're a little longer and a
little more complicated to make because
you want them purified but they will
come and then come to you and ready to
use in about a week
once you have your probes and the Plex
set reagents in hand you're ready to get
started with these the one thing that we
always start with are some titration at
a days and the objective of the
titration assays are to check the
protocol that you're using to get your
RNA or your lysate and to check to make
sure your probes are working you also
want to establish a range of cells or
total RNA concentrations that's going to
give you optimal range of expression you
don't want it to be too low and you
certainly don't want it to be too high
to where it's saturating counts out and
you're not getting good-good counts so
that's another good reason to do two
titration assays and you also if you
would happen to have a gene that may be
very highly expressive and other others
that are expressing very low there are
some attenuation modifications that we
can do to high expressing genes that
will allow you to bring that expression
down and you can recalculate that back
up later but it will bring it down so
that all fits into the same assay and
you don't have to do something separate
off for those highly expressive genes
so let's take a look at applying the
Plex set to some case studies and these
are some things that we are doing here
at Dartmouth with some of our
researchers one we wanted to look at an
alternative to see if this would be an
alternative for the qPCR technology that
were that we use here a lot we wanted to
look at costs and see the turnaround
times and also we wanted to see the
correlation between results we also want
to see how versatile the Plex set could
be and so we kind of ran a found some
opposites type studies one where we were
looking at the time of day physiological
and transcriptomic levels in response to
onset of droughts and plants and and
then the other was a CRISPR now say that
we were were helping out with we were
looking at elements in the coding genome
and non-coding genome that may or may
not regulate Mik expression in
colorectal adenocarcinoma so you can see
those are fairly different in their
scopes and what's going on there so
let's start with this with the CRISPR
project and take a look at what we were
doing there we talked about how we're
looking at gain and loss of function and
was secret regarding scenic expression
and so once the CRISPR transfection was
done those cells were sent down to our
flow cytometry lab and those cells and
sorted looking for the presence of a
particular cat tag that screen or
presence/absence sorry
so they were looking for a tag the see
Mickey gee SP fusion tag that they had
induced into these particular cell lines
to see if it was there this particular
assay at this point was profiling
nucleolus and and Simek gene targets to
see how they were interacting with each
other and they decided they wanted to
test the purified RNA versus the cell
lysate because using cell lysate would
really save them a lot of time
so a crisper project overview these were
the probes that these were the targets
that we designed probes for obviously
the scenic and the the GE GFP fusion we
had a probe for probe for scenic probe
for egfp approp for the nucleolus what
they were looking at two housekeeping
genes and then the probe trap which was
also a potential modifier that they were
looking at so that that got thrown into
this particular asset they really didn't
have many more genes that they wanted to
look at with this particular project but
that was plenty for us to start with so
we talked about doing a titration assay
and so this is the titration assay that
we set up for the CRISPR we used five
different levels of lysate titration
starting with 10,000 cells and then down
to five
two-and-a-half 1250 and six 625 cells we
then wanted to check the Mik expression
because we were afraid it may be
expressing a very high and we wanted to
make sure we weren't going to have to
use some attenuation processes with that
so we ran a cell line that had very high
expression mid expression and low
expression for Mik we ran a control of
just water and to make sure we weren't
getting some strange backgrounds and
other things going on and then for the
RNA of the be extracted on RNA we use
three different concentrations for that
at 200 nanograms 100 nanograms and
fifty-minute grams and so this saw was
determined so we ran these 12 samples
out
did the overnight hybridisation
washington looked at these and realized
right away that our lysis titration
didn't work real well on this on a
couple of the levels that we were hoping
to get it was a difference between two
protocols that we had tried to mix
together and we clearly were not using
enough lysis buffer in the well set up
that the cells were growing so we
decided we were going to repeat that
titration assay again that's one of the
reasons you do the titration assay is to
make sure you have your protocols set up
what it did give us was information that
the titration line lysate because some
of them did work well at five thousand
cells was going to be a good level for
us to use and that the mick itself was
not expressing so high that we were
going to have to use any attenuation on
it and the the RNA titration showed that
100 nanograms was going to be just fine
with that so we took that information
and there was one thing we didn't see we
didn't get a hyde width for the mick gif
our GFP fusion probe and so we were
concerned that maybe something was wrong
with that
so we then picked some cell lines and
I'll show you the data on this one of
the second titration sa so we pick some
cell lines to make sure that indeed our
Mickey GFP effusion was working and that
we could indeed pick that up so what you
see here are the raw data up in the
table above that has been that was
processed and then the heat map that was
a result of that that particular data
and what you see here is we are
definitely getting the expression that
we wanted to see when you look at the
the GF P control you can see that yes
indeed we are picking up that expression
and that the probes are working fine
fine for that but you can see we didn't
get a lot of the cell lines weren't
showing that fusion like we were hoping
to see but in any case this validated
what we wanted to see so next we took
this to doing 96 different samples all
at the same time with this particular
probe set and I'll show you the results
of that next
so these are the raw data coming off
that screen this is actually just the
first two rows the Rho a and Rho B
obviously if I showed you all eight rows
you wouldn't be able to see any of the
numbers so I did limit this slide to
just the first two rows but just so that
you got a feel for how the data is going
to be coming out of the digital calendar
and displayed in the end solver software
when you start looking at that then this
data was then turned into the various
heat maps for the full 96-well plate and
the experimental hypothesis for this was
that the precursor nucleo land and sea
mick
would when one was positive the other
would be positive and they would be
expressing it similar you know in
continuous reflective levels and indeed
that's exactly what we were seeing with
the 96-well plate and got very nice
results from that we also saw positive
expression from the housekeeping gene
that we used the e 1 FB 3 and the trap
gene which is also related to Mik
expression was showing some good
expression there actually the level of
expression surprised the researchers on
this particular one so that was
something they were going to investigate
us some more as to why it was at that
that particular level however this great
results for the C mech egfp
fusions really came up negative and
showing that this fusion wasn't there
and they're really facing the so so the
CRISPR our strategy for this fusion was
not working in these cells as they were
working with them and so they decided
they were going to need to rethink this
a little bit but we can see we got
negative negative
from that these results they went back
and confirmed this using qPCR and flow
again and they confirm the exact results
that we're seeing here see and both what
we have both cell lysate and RNA
extracts in this one and they were
consistent with each other also
as a little bonus we did throw a few
things and we threw a microbacterium
probe in with their sets since they were
only running a few probes they were
happy to see this because a few months
back that was something that they were
fighting with and so this was run with
their assays and that too came up
negative which of course they were very
happy to see and without the fusion you
can see the egfp also came up as a
negative in this particular assay so a
summary of the CRISPR research of
current tag method was showing negative
screening our QC results were all
correct and accurate with the Flex sent
the results all were verified as we said
by qPCR and Flo needed to develop a new
tagging strategy for this particular
experiment and that's exactly what
they're doing right now and we got the
same results from the purified RNA as we
did the cell lysate which was a real
help because again using life aids can
save you an enormous amount of time
especially when you're doing as many
cell lines as you usually do with CRISPR
and experimental time you utilizing the
Flex set was reduced from several
several weeks to one week by using the
Flex set strategies as opposed to using
qPCR
right now I'm going to divulge here a
little not diverge I should say a little
bit the Nano string is offering a CRISPR
grant program and they're going to
choose five applicants off for this
program winners will receive a one
hundred ninety two reactions of 24
custom gene targets the abstract
submission for deadline for this to get
in on this is the 19th of this month so
you've got a little time but not a lot
of time and if you want some more
information on this you can go to the
Nano string web site and enter spring
calm and look up CRISPR grant and you
should be able to find some information
on that so let's change speeds here a
little bit and let's go ahead and take a
look at the second study that we were
working with this is a circadian gene
expression study and around.but topsis
at least it that was the first step to
that that changes it a little bit this
was done by katie Greenham ping Liu and
dr. Moog and his laboratory and this was
something that they had started before
the Plex set came out so they were
already doing some qPCR on these things
on this at on these samples that they
had the design was this there were seven
genotypes probe time points for each
genotype and three different three
biological replicates for every every
one of those so there were 42 target
genes 3 reference genes and this worked
out to the equivalent of doing 12,000
and 96 nana stirring reactions or over
48,000 qpcr reactions and what the
12,000 that nana stirring reactions
works out to be with the plex set is
doing 6
96-well Nana stirring plates she had to
because she had 42 or actually total 45
genes she was looking at she had to do
two different probe sets and she did
three plates for her first probe set and
three plates for her second probe set
and so one thing they did was they
started they wanted to know right away
was the cost of this and and this is a
cost analysis of their particular
experiment at the time that they they
were doing that obviously with qPCR you
need cDNA reagents and they were using
6.64 cents per sample this is the way
they broke that down obviously with Peck
Plex set because it's a straight
hybridization
there is no requirements to make cDNA
assay reagents for the qPCR were 22
cents a sample whereas with the Plex
said it was 82 cents total cost when
they added all up of what they thought
they were going to need to do was just
under $14,000 for the for the qpcr where
and the Plex set was eleven thousand
three hundred dollars you know fairly
close actually cost per data point when
they were looking that was a dollar 16
for the qPCR and 82 cents for the Plex
and the time and this is this is where
the real big difference
obviously was you know was going to take
her three months to run that many two
PCR assays whereas with the Plex set it
was only going to take her two weeks now
granted this is their specific situation
and what what platforms they had to run
their qpcr on but it it it certainly
highlights some of the things that you
could look at
for your various situations no sorry
yeah Costin time comparison for that
alright so looking at a comparison
between the Flex set and the qpcr and
some of the differences and this was
something they wanted to see so
obviously with the qPCR you can run RNA
or DNA samples Plex set right now that
specifically RNA and we talked about how
they're working on other essays now
reverse transcription you need to do
with the qPCR but there's none with the
Flex set nucleic acid assessment yeah
you need to be using high quality RNA
for the to PCR with Plex set like you
know obviously if you can use lysate
good quality RNA never hurts an essay
but you can do license with the Plex set
so assessment isn't necessarily required
target sequence locations yeah that's
something you want to know for both
assays and slice variants yes absolutely
you want to know information on your
splice variants technical replicates got
to do a minimum but you better be doing
a minimum of three usually that's not
enough EMU maybe should be doing four to
five on some of these depending on what
you're working on but there are no
technical replicates needed with the
Plex set multiplexing multiplexing qPCR
with two probes is really not that
difficult but as you add probes of
complexity starts to get up there with
Plex set multiplexing is not a problem
in matter of fact they stop there at 24
obviously with Nana string says they can
multiplex 800 samples in a single
reaction that's not a problem for them
primer sequence and manufacturing
information now obviously you want to
know that for both assays qPCR protocol
because there's so many
different types of polymerase and
reagents and kits out there that's all
something that you need to track and
stay consistent with especially if
you're going to be publishing this
information with Plex set it's always
the same protocol and and reagents other
than obviously your primers and post
reaction processing nothing with the
qPCR of course but with the Plex set yes
you need to stick that into the prep
station and have that cleaned up and
then counted through the digital counter
so that is part of the process but
that's all automated
there's a lot less validation requires
with the Plex set you know with to PCR
you need to be validating your negative
RT controls you got need to be looking
for in addition that may be going on in
your reactions or contamination of RNA
or DNA depending on what you're asking
you need to make sure samples are
optimized and that your SA has been
optimized for efficiency because if you
have certain genes amplifying at
different rates there's no way you can
really compare them once your reference
genes obviously and biology you should
use biological replicates and with qpcr
you need no template controls and with
the multiplexing you need to know the
efficiency not only of each individual
genes but the efficiency of the group
together with that with plex set it's
much cleaner certainly we talked about
optimizing sample input and we do that
with our titration assays and then yes
you want to know your reference genes
and have those in there and biological
replicates certainly do not hurt
especially when you're doing large
studies across many different plates
so we've got some we have reproducible
we want to show some reproducible
results that Katy got on her essays here
up sorry there they come they see these
are the these are this is looking at box
plot these are box plots showing the
spread of three different time points
for her subset of genes of three
different plates that were replicated
now I also want to point out these are
the first three plates that Katie ran on
these and when you look at those box
plots and their lengths you can see that
the data on those even though they
should be expressing at different areas
each of those genes are is quite tight
so she was able to get very good
reproducible results from what she was
doing using the Flex set and considering
those were the first time she would even
touch the naina string assay it's quite
impressive and but it's very
reproducible people doing to PCR for the
first time certainly don't have good
tight data like that and it's a very
much a learned process so again looking
at replicates here we can she use these
scores to demonstrate how close her
replicates between probes set and probe
a second probe set were on the three
different plates plates a B and C that
she labeled here and you can see that
she got very tight replication between
her plates and everything was within two
standard deviations of the me
and so showing what a versatile scene
that this is a pretty versatile tool
they decided to use the Flex set in a
little different fashion from what they
were doing they were wanted to take a
look at the time of day and
physiological and transcriptomic level
changes in response to drought for
Brassica Rapa and and they partnered up
with some researchers from the
University of Wyoming in Laramie and
then decided to take this essay on so
what this assay consisted of was a water
was withheld from 16 old day plants 48
hours to their harvest so we were they
were establishing just a very mild
drought with them there were no visible
signs of wilting at this stage in the
plants that they saw and based on that I
must be putting my home plants through
drought all the time the leaf tissues
were collected every four hours for two
cycles and they took those samples and
did RNA seek on them they also did
physiological measurements that were
collected a stromal conductance or
respiration photosynthetic rate or
photosynthesis and they looked at non
structural carbohydrates to see you know
what the sugar content of these
particular plants were and how that
might be related
so what they did once they had their RNA
seek data they applied a wait awaited
gene correction network analysis to
generate the well well-watered or the
watered plants versus the drought plants
transcriptomic Networks physiology data
was collected revealing extensive time
the extensive time add a variation
review let me start that over the
physiological data revealed extensive
time of day variation in the gene
expression that match the dynamics in
the physiology and researchers applied a
security and rhythm circadian analysis
program to identify the genes responding
at specific times of the day based on
the physiological data and then a string
was used to validate a subset of the
target genes that this information gave
them to confirm the changes in light
harvesting complex processes metabolism
occurring at the onset of the drought
response so they're really looking at
just very light drought initial drought
response of these particular plants
below you're seeing their sampling
strategy that we talked about collecting
when their collection points were day at
night for two days
so as I said they were trying to capture
the early response time of day had a
major they saw had a major influence on
the plants regarding the drug responses
to the drought this is not Nana stirring
data I should say this was the data that
they got from their other essays going
on and which pointed to them which
particular genes they wanted to look at
with the Nano string data so in a chart
a they're they're looking at the maximum
efficiency and how that may have changed
a maximum efficiency of photosynthesis
and how that changed in the watered
plants versus the drop plants and in the
lower chart they're what they were
looking at was the carbohydrates
presence in those plants and where you
see little stars on top like there and
there or I should say little stars on
top you see if I can get a pointer
working here for there and there were
significant to the different types I
guess that arrow didn't work in any case
hopefully you can see those stars I know
that charts a little tough to see there
so they were again still trying to
capture early responses these are
examples of mean expressions of data
from set subsets of genes identified as
drought responsive in the network and
and so these were analyzed corresponding
to the geo enrichment resulted in
analysts analyzed by a virtual plant a
database so looking at these they were
able to figure out which particular
genes they wanted to use with the naina
string as i showed you ahead of time
so once they got to the nano string and
they just decided which jeans they
wanted to use this was a validation of
35 we RNA seek validation I should say
they use 35 grout responsive genes to
support the temporal alterations of
light harvesting processes and
metabolism and they plotted that out
based on the drought and well-watered
and the Gruber time frames and lights on
when lights were particular on on or off
the blue boxes to your right indicate
genes that they wanted that they saw
some nice significant differences from
and we were able to validate using the
Flex set to validate their RNA seek and
this is some graphs of these particular
eight genes that they they had in the
blue boxes they're each data point
represented a mean normal counts of five
individual plants and the gene camps
were then normalized to their controls
obviously the gray shading shows the
dark periods and stars represents
significance between these particular
genes at the time between the drought
and well-watered plants
so in summary here on the encounter plex
tech technology does show that it is a
great alternate to cube the qPCR
technology it can be less expensive
there's no upfront Pro validation that
you need to do the turnaround time can
be as well as a one six what it would be
for to PCR it's a very effective and
easy multiplexing of the samples and
gene targets and the simple lisen go
protocol eliminates the RNA purification
cDNA conversions and amplifications that
you would need to do for the qPCR and I
think we've definitely shown that it's a
very versatile tool tool here
demonstrate the success of both plant
and CRISPR researchers research going on
here can be expanded to other research
applications such as biomarker
validation and cell screening and drug
development it's a great tool for Core
labs like mine because it opens up new
ways that and offerings that we can do
for our clients and it definitely was
you successfully here for the RNA seek
results like to say thank you to my
close lab and naughty Premal and my coal
for the CRISPR work that they were that
they provided and the mclubbe lab
specifically KT Greenham and Pig pain
lieu for the for the drought resistant
research that they shared with us and of
course the nana string technologies
arrow record kit Fuhrman and Anisha
for helping us put these things together
and guiding us through
the initial launches of this particular
product thank you so much for that
informative presentation Kristian we
want to begin with our Q&A segment so
here's a reminder as to how audience
members can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left if you are
unable to get to those questions for
enable to get to questions due to time
constraints Christian will be answering
submitted questions via email so let's
take a look at our first sub questions
Christian an audience member would like
to know can you explain the advantages
of life and protocol
yeah the licen go protocol with Lysa you
know when you're extracting RNA and so
forth you lose a lot of that you can
lose a lot of that the products have
gotten very good but it's more expensive
and time consuming obviously to extract
the RNA so with the licen go protocol
you know being able to just go into the
tissue culture wells and lyse those
cells up and drawing out the supernatant
from that and being able to run that
right away is much less expensive and a
lot quicker a process so it helps you
get to the end result where you're
trying to go and get your information so
that you can keep moving forward instead
of doing longer processes to get the
same information thank you for that um
there's another great question how can
this technology help core labs
well I can tell you how we plan to use
it we're a very small electric lab as a
very small they're only two of us and so
when it came to doing Q PCR which a lot
of researchers were hoping we would be
able to come to us all the time and hope
we can do for them
we just don't have the bandwidth to
handle it we just don't have the
bandwidth to handle all the QC and extra
steps that need to be done to properly
set up your Q PCR assays so it's not
something we could ever ever really
consider offering without taking on more
personnel but with the Flex set assay
because we're not doing that particular
QC and it kind of fits more into the
natural flow of what we're doing with
our regular Nanna string assays this is
all of a sudden an area that we can
offer very good services for and I
really like the way it's very tight data
and very reproducible which is something
that we're all trying to do continually
and tighten up our protocols so this is
this is just a big wind situation as far
as our core goes and so I'm anxious to
to start getting more and more groups
doing this wonderful thank you so much
and another person I'd like to know you
showed some data for plant research and
CRISPR can this technology be used for
other applications yeah sure uh you know
if you're it could be used for any type
of validation or or even if you know as
long as you know a sequence or target
that you're going after this is a great
way to do some of that even if you're
going to be doing more something more
substantial and you just want to
validate some of the thoughts that
you're having this is a great assay to
use to get some preliminary data to show
that what you're thinking is possible
it's almost as long as you're looking at
you know transcriptional events here and
this is a technology that certainly can
be applied to that thank you for that we
have time for one more question what is
the maximum number of targets you can
multiplex is that work for complicated
and the next number well I would say
that the Plex set is is set for 12 to 24
and and surprisingly I've had when I
talk to people they do like to move up
sometimes from the 24 and do 48 and
that's all within the realm of Plex set
to do 48 targets at the same time you
just have to do an additional plate with
a different set of 24 probes but that
said once once you're up in that range
you might consider maybe going to
standard Nana stirring assays which of
course those you can multiply Plex up to
800 targets trade off there is the Plex
set is if you've got a lot of samples
you want to focus in on 24 or 48 if you
want to go to particular probes that you
may be interested in as you move up and
you want to get more sample higher
multiplexing issue there as you need to
reduce the number of samples or it's
just not as quickly to produce as run as
many samples through the system well
hope that answered the question
I think it did thank you so much again
Christian what a wonderful presentation
I'd like to thank the lab roots for
keeping today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available on-demand viewing through
August 2017 keep an eye out for an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webinar will be available
we play we encourage you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
next time bye-bye